my name
welcome back to the showers have a good
time good time
astragal celibate whoo whoa thanks but
thanks for Facebook should not be in
that I forgot to relay my gun I even
remember I read a comment about it
saying oh sweet baby Jesus you know what
are we doing facebooking taxes we shoot
don't wait whoa whoa whoa what he did so
close to me that's really awkward
Facebook odd to Hill really awkward
Facebook hey it was only collecting
bowling balls I thought I was in the
shower
well that was has for my health not fine
and dandy and it's tiny 90 need two guys
dropped the soap and they are now
prostitutes on the street named tyke
quietly and rock on down all right
[ __ ] Facebook man so I don't really
think we should bowling be bowling so
much whoa watch are you doing that
setting another gum let's drop this one
and let's pick up the Advocate Appy 3:45
[ __ ] oh I can strap people hit it I
don't have any ammo though that's a
bummer
this is quite the dilemma quiet today
dial am i indeed
wasn't this a puzzle there's something
strange about dr. Parnell
well isn't that name is lovely I just
love sniffing sweaty shoes it's like
this thing it's a switch between the
sheath
I'm sorry but I really don't know what
I'm doing here doing what make a nose
ants
oh by the way how everyone was like wait
everyone's like oh no the new patch no
Peter won't be able to say but hey guess
what guess who's not updating the patch
Sandra Bullock it's not doing it she's
not playing this game son it's quite
difficult for her or maybe she is
playing this game I mean Sandra Bullock
is pretty hardcore check out there I'm
just saying alright let's go here
well [ __ ] me I just went in circles we
need to find the doctor I don't wait
think you win
doctor got to make sexual noises Hey
look at that hot it's like it's like the
why you know guys the pollicis looks
like arms I'm just saying just saying
guess it's back back go Kim penis back
pee on your friend oh what's that
how's the engine there's apparently like
a thing I need and pick up here I forgot
about we'll check it out again that it
is a material then I can drop the
lantern so you need to be awesome
all right baby I'm dropping you just for
a second because I have a flashlight
this is penumbra [ __ ] and then we
combine jutsu doesn't white language
what do you know I have a flashlight
anyway I don't know how it's better but
I really don't know where to go I guess
I should cheat but I don't really feel
like thinking about Lady Gaga these days
I'll just go in here it's definitely
here at acting fancy phones get them oh
I can switch it off and on yeah yeah
it's like party in here whoa
[Music]
okay back to the bowling hall where's my
gun all right and then she came up and
then we combine you can't [ __ ] me okay
if we find an mo we'll go back to you
right don't worry I'm not leaving you
behind
this is penumbra badass style can i push
you I want to strike hey
serene for me [ __ ] I'm really lifted
today I'm fighting too many things I
don't want all of these things I don't
know what to do with it
alright let's use this room then I guess
eat that [ __ ] Wow we being really
productive in their own way there we go
thanks but it's gotta hide something
from me I know he's hiding something
alright let's don't really know
to be honest so let's just go back I
suppose look at the heart go pity I love
you
let me give me a bj later what
disgusting
all right let's go back here and then
somewhere I don't even know anymore
señoritas everywhere the game crash
again I then all right
oh I hate those little [ __ ] Oh both
back off back off back off
stay down girl stay down
freakin why is it raining all this side
up all right we put down the power so I
guess now we can advance somewhere
hopefully I don't know how long I sign
any bother huh
hey it's got the thunders hello send one
in here and I'm taking a shower without
me naked
oh no they promised they were like hey
penny will never take a shower without
you why wouldn't why would they do that
right it's flashlight is awesome I love
it I love it I love it I love it okay so
maybe we need to go
somewhere why do we go on come on baby
just might be what you wanted
I mean if you're in oh this open this up
and let's go progress
okay I would just need to figure out is
that good luck magazine that means we
will find some enemies tell you oh yes
there yes
sexy voice I'd love to talk to people
with a blood and gas masks yeah you are
you [ __ ] my life
come closer come closer Simon you're so
crazy so you can rub my nipples yeah
you're right good point Simon why do you
want so many guns just you see talking
in terms he's talking about my penis
right now there's a penis in the bowling
alley oh I get it
ah I have it already I found it like a
mouse all right I've been told that I
should give him the gun to get the good
ending so we are going to give him
together
ha natural he thought it why would I
trust the guy with the [ __ ] gas mask
and blood period something now in return
here that oh that little [ __ ] oh oh
he's going down
yes going fat down
why would he shoot me like that and hard
it hurts I tell you alright let's kill
him they all knocked it lock that [ __ ]
oh oh oh I'm gonna look at this window
and then I gotta Cal yeah where is he
where's the naked ladies where so make
it girls everywhere come on use the
mouse to look around or use attack
accounts
why would I make a ladies what it says
someone getting raped in yet
hello I don't get this what am I
supposed to do here a foam oh no this is
too epic calling mom
I almost call my own Rambler I can do
that then I'm gonna get a bunch of Bruce
being I like it alright so we need to
find a way to use the telescope what why
are we using the telescope where do you
want to look huh why do you want to let
why huh long hear it anything is hello
hello buckets closet keep it staying
awesome I guess so we got a key to enter
here the doctor locked it all will
[ __ ] miss Kruger oh there's not here
and see it okay there's got to be
another door then you find the other
things wherever that is
woo whoa guess not Oh eNOS [ __ ] whoa
you're awesome holy [ __ ] I want that
outfit sexy and he knows it he speaks
acts nice oh my god you smell delicious
oh my lord holy [ __ ]
I got come from like a no sales staff
door what the [ __ ] is the staff room
stop this I know you speak at Nick's and
you're proud of it what what are you
doing she's like hey disrespecting us oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa this won't
stop thank you [ __ ]
you can't do that whoa whoa whoa
there we go that's one down bros it's
the other one
merry little sugar hey mama I'll go pick
that out though
hey serene whoa whoa whoa whoa
you little [ __ ] I know you were gonna
come and not so soon ah
Kruger's I need to drop something
I can't drop anything I need everything
that I have all right I'll take the
later okay come on baby come on baby
girl what are you doing well thanks ash
Diggs [ __ ] don't talk it unless
you want it freakin birds Freaker okay
so awesome my mom
rubbing my nipples all day why can I
take their ax it makes no sense all
right I'm going up come on
this [ __ ] stop all of yo you're
[ __ ] crazy all of you you know that
mental hospital that's what this [ __ ] is
what are you doing here anyway you know
that okay so now I can we can go in here
by a keypad our Z
all right that's a problem whether there
should be an unlocked door somewhere
that's smashing someone is behind the
door okay maybe this one nope all right
sweets a guy boxed up
when you find a door that's locked its
simply locked one does not simply lock a
door
what why not I'll check these maybes
downstairs probably I hate you
Oh hate those I hate them
I'm reloading
[Music]
your story is that this one yeah this is
mine it is ah I can't find it ah ah ah
I'll check it out for the next episode
but yeah I landed here see you next
episode like a favorite if you enjoyed
subscribe to call my brother today and
I'll see you whenever I see him fell
down for you
hope you happy I should slap your vagina